let's talk about saving mr banks i got
to watch this uh
film last night with my wife and it we
were blown away
just an amazing film this is i like it
too and uh i
was we're done good night
i'm not in it that much so that when i
when i yeah i mean i worked for about
three and a half weeks so
when you get to finally see you see all
this movie you're not in with colin
farrell and emma and
jason jason schwartzman and bj uh uh bj
novak
yeah it's a it's a it's bradley it's a
it's a great story
uh the story of walt disney had promised
his kids i'm going to make the movie of
of mary poppins i think he promised his
kids and also he might have thought that
he'll you'll make some money off of this
yes
you know profit profit i'm sure he's not
a dope in that way yeah
and he wants to make this movie he
thinks this is the movie to make but he
doesn't have the rights he has to go
yeah and she hates everything there is
to hate about americans and movies and
and walt disney so it's a
it was a it was a battle of a battle of
wills and
and disney just came in and out and said
fix this fellas fix it
you know what's uh really impressive
about the film is
they they've recreated old-time
disneyland they've really recreated the
early it's the early 60s and you really
feel like this is it's walt disney at
disneyland
we got to shoot at disney we got to
shoot at disneyland period everything
and they changed some of the colors they
went back to the original uh
art design for some of it and to be in
disneyland come on man
well you know before it opens
yeah it was just us we didn't have the
run of the place because we had to get
to work but when you get there and
there's nobody there it's like oh i get
it i'm 13. i
i'm dead at 13 and i've come to heaven
this is where we get to live now did you
learn and did you get to spook around
did you learn any of the old
yeah because you always think there are
these mysteries and myths about disney
you ask questions like what happened to
this
ride and they tell you why there's no
sky buckets anymore
remember the sky bucket sure got him you
caught him in tomorrowland he took him
fantastic land they went right through
the heart of the matterhorn came out the
other side
and one of the problems was there were a
lot of people who were trying to join
let's call it the mile high club you're
kidding
in the sky buckets there was other
naughty stuff going on but there were
people that tried to how do we say this
get the deed done
um how to enjoy the e-ticket what
[Laughter]
i don't know but they were trying how
much time how much how long is that
right that was it i mean i remember
doing it it was like maybe four and a
half minutes from tomorrow that offense
yeah exactly
oh no way that means that means
everything had to be out of its foil
packet
it had to you know everything had to be
i could do it i could do it three times
on that one
[Applause]
they'd have they have guys saying they
basically like
sky bucket number 57. and sure enough
there'd be two people in sky bucket
number 57
let's say they were enjoying their climb
up the matterhorn
they would they would be met in in in
fantasyland by a keystone cop and a
western sheriff
with walkie talkies in their ears that's
fantastic
saying i think you two musketeers are
going to be escorted to the other side
of the berm
so that's one of the reasons they shut
down the sky bucket that's absolutely
amazing nefarious
nefarious activities